mensch was der wartung den anfang hat er
nie gesehen bei einer youtube herzlich
willkommen zu der bluttat von meiner
hamburger wohnungen hier normale leute
machen einen rückzieher wenn sie
einziehen bei mir ist es eher das
gegenteil jetzt aber hat sich aus denn
jetzt kann ich meine damit alten und
jetzt daran lassen und zur letzten
monate
auch scheißegal ich fahre mal mit der
tür
das ist auf jeden fall der
eingangsbereich vor meiner wohnung ich
finde ganz geheilt wenn meine wohnung
betritt oder ein haus hat keine ahnung
was das man einfach blickachsen hat und
hier in einer diese blickachse
steht derzeit komplett risch hat hier
die ganzen lichter in einer linie guckt
nach draußen wenn man noch hier guckt
hat man hier die ganzen nicht an einer
linie und das ist so quasi der flur
hinten im privaten bereich küche alles
offen also ich alle hatten die 190
verrat mich aber summe eigentlich nur
zwei oder drei zimmer kein bock auf
türen habe ich bin
ich damit kommen das ist ja eine überall
muss gegen die schiebetüren gemacht oder
türen wie die hier vorne
[Musik]
man sieht ein paar nächsten schwarze
wand gelernt ich wollte wieder schön
machen dass wir gar nicht sieht das ist
überhaupt das sind die tür raus kommt
und dann habe ich jeden tag
sagt jetzt auf jeden fall ist dass ihr
der ganze küchenbereich ist wir haben
alle möglichen unfall gegeben beispiel
ist auch über den stecken kleinigkeiten
schauen warum hast du so ein echtes habe
ich mich auch gefragt was das kunstwerk
steckdosen und zum kathrin in der wand
du siehst so orange aus gerade das ist
auf jeden fall so schlecht das sieht
gerade wenn es extrem geil aus weil es
einfach so natur mäßig ist wir haben
überall so led leisten verbaut sondern
indirekten beleuchtung eigentlich müsste
bei nacht wenn dann ist alles noch ein
bisschen schöner aus aber das ist auf
jeden fall die kirche das dünnste der
küchenschrank
er funktioniert auf einer der
funktioniert sonst nie diese ganze
scheiße und so auch hier das geht warum
funktioniert dann ist auf einmal
ok auf einmal das sonst geht das mehr
als 1000 mal
1000 fingerabdrücke und das oft großes
dieser ofen kommen hier um die kinder
wenn man irgendwie am kochen ist kommt
man die irgendwie zu geben und dann
drückt man auch sehen was uns auf einem
grill so und 500 grad an also auf jeden
fall küche wichtig dass sie halt in
einer ecke ist dass sie schwarz also
dass gerade gesunken ist nicht so
richtig auffällt weil ich mag das aber
die mit dynamo und verzierungen und dann
ist die küche so ein highlight weil ein
gerät gekauft so ich finde zum
wohnzimmer sollen mehr so cool sein
das problem ist dass wir schon voll für
die kollegen haben eigentlich fest
anders ich habe einfach komplett
angezogen gestützt so weit weg von mir
kochen ist wenn wir leute sind es nie
was trinken essen hier menschen sitzen
fernseher gucken und vor allem an alle
die aussicht angucken hat man quasi hier
den fernseher hier habe ich eine
terrasse ich hab ich eine terrasse und
der ausblick ist halt ein bisserl
hamburg gucken ich habe lust auf ein
hamburger
generell alles einbauschränke
[Musik]
dabei hab ich einen podcast folgen vor
ein zwei jahren wieder für diesen tisch
gelegt ich möchte jetzt und rivalen wie
schulen und seitdem besteht sagt jäger
ist das geilste möbelstück ist
eigentlich braun damit sie bald schwarz
lackieren lassen und so ist auch extrem
dreckig weil meine reinigungskräfte
haben mir gekündigt von monaten seit dem
ipad nicht gesagt wir wollen offen
beworbenen dann habe ich auf jeden fall
so ein beton hält was ein bisschen
essbereich schulbereich von dem
eingangsbereich abschotten soll ihre
schadprogramme junge nellessen wird das
ist keine ahnung die sich dafür
interessieren wir haben ja vor dem mord
an tobias grauel amt eigentlich eure das
tolle ist es die hier nicht so schnell
und dann haben wir hier vorne meinen
aufnahme zimmerecke büro ein gästezimmer
die nämlich halt meine videos auf und er
hat auch schon dass der ton deutlich
besser ist es die daran dass wir hier
die hela design platten aber auch
schwarz lackieren lassen durch drei mal
weil man die auch mit zu schrauben rein
machen muss eine heidenarbeit hier viele
youtube aber irgendwie so kann er so
schaumstoff an den wänden das kann ich
nicht so schön und dass sie dir echt
geil aus und das haben an der decke
haben wir hier das haben auch im
essbereich zurückgezogen da kann es mir
rüber film einmal gut dass noch ihr blut
durchgang blickachsen und überall luft
kann rumlaufen das ist auch
obwohl andere sagen
hallo ich bin so eine schlechte
kamerafrau hautnah ja allerdings dass
dies dann auf jeden fall mein
schreibtisch das ist eine riesige
holzklasse die einfach hingelegt habe
ich brauche diesen trick stadt nicht der
leute mit irgendwie hochfahren oder hier
weiß man dass man die sache ist wenn ich
nicht dann mache jetzt das beleuchtet
unter tageslicht schiene ich habe ja
alles angeschlossen das die ganze kabel
um verdeckte technik dahinter ist hier
dresdner sc ich will den auch nicht
krass präsentierten in dem gefährt
draufsteht muss ist einfach das als
clean ist und hier kann man dann
natürlich alle geführt zu machen denn
die ich ja wünschen sagte das ist nicht
mein arbeitszimmer was sich abschirmen
will sondern auch noch ein gästezimmer
und der gäste da sind kann man nicht
sagen wenn man die tür zu die türe zu
ich habe noch so eine kleine
fernbedienung werden soll die anlage
natürlich kommt drin sein gegenüber
nicht
so ein leinwand runter und dann kann man
hier oben die schranktür aufmachen um
dadurch aus dem schrank hinter zu
klappen man hätte ein entspanntes
gästezimmer oder wenn ich jetzt videos
aufnehmen ist das halt auch immer so und
keine videos aufnimmt ist jetzt echt da
hinten
bestimmten das geil ist halt auch dass
durch diese schiebetüren nicht über
effekt wie durch eine normale tür
erzeugt wird von wegen raum abschließend
zu bleiben sondern bin ja meistens
wirklich hier alleine und oder mit dir
halt zumindest zusammen da jetzt nicht
mit kindern oder das mitbewohner hier
sind dann hat man halt alles irgendwie
offen ich mache das hier lieber wenn
alles offen ist und ich so einen raum
tür zu dem schluss heißt weil wir ein
wenn der garten erhalten arbeit das hier
alles so klien vernünftig hin zu bringen
mit dem parkett weil das ist auch ein
douglasien boden schaut nicht mehr die
zu bieten es sind die kleinigkeiten
das ist so perfekt gemacht worden keine
einzige diele hat einen horizontalen
verschnitt drin wenn er von den beiden
ist für mich einfach mein größtes idol
und eine person die ich über alles liebe
hier übrigens noch mal sorry dass hier
so viele kartons und alles möglich die
normalerweise ist ja alles clean und der
durchgang geht bis hinten rein aber wir
sind ja gerade im umzugsstress
ich könnte so viel erzählen allein über
diese feuermelder lüftungsanlage und
über diese downloads kann ich so viel
erzählen aber doch das juckt wirklich
kein schwein und die kommen jetzt
einfach hierdurch durch zu durch die
fast alle die erst mal gäste partner ich
bin so im stress das jetzt auf jeden
fall des gästezimmers kamera getestet
hat meine gäste schlafen auf dem klub
das hier ist auf jeden fall ist gästeklo
ich habe hier genau das gleiche gemacht
wie ich auch damals meiner kölner
wohnung gemacht habe und zwar so eine
wand sondern tafel waren vor allem
möglichen von mir noch unterschreiben
können hier ist halt toiletten fließen
die fliesen dass er auch sondern achten
er guckt euch mal an wie sich diese
fiesen sind das ist bei etwa 20 meter 20
für so perfekt wie fliesen das sagt er
alles nichts
dann wenn wir auf jeden fall den wasch
blog tisch die auch immer dusche und aus
er hat zumindest über mir das auch viel
ohne das
abkommen auf jedenfalls hier mit die
einzige tür die einzigen türen in der
ganzen wohnung sind nicht zum gäste
waren uns im privaten bereich wenn das
wohin wir alles öffentlich mit freude da
sind macht die tür nicht immer zu weil
hier befindet sich nur meine ankleide
weil schlaf zu hören bei bad
hast du nie benutzt
vielleicht wenn man hier auf jeden fall
reinkommt sieht man als erstes links die
anklage ist es auch schon komplett
ausgebucht alles es ist der denkbar
dümmste wurde in einem ups machen es ist
gerade beim einpacken hat erst wissen
aufgefallen dass ich noch nie hier die
wohnung so mäßig gezeigt habe ich weiß
was mir bei der stadion beleuchtung
gemerkt habe dass es richtig wäre ich
liebte es hier drin
rituell jedes mein hintergrund gemacht
ich werde den hintergrund
münsters durch
auch wenn man zu anderen seite
coschützer welt sichtbar wird sobald in
der waschmaschine
gestalt auf jeden fall marketing
handtasche bis die daten geklaut wurden
haben wir hier noch ein teppich liegen
wir haben hier im bett vor ich glaube
das ist liegen die wahren die auch das
ist auch egal ob mein sofa vor damit
auch zu viele leute mal gefragt ist auch
in der gegend waren immer ganz kurz info
wer weiß mehr tun demo er ist der boss
zufällig dieses wissen wollten und dann
wenn man sich quasi umdreht sieht man
erstmal hier eine riesige bilder plant
ihr ja da ich mir dabei gedacht wer sich
wie grimms du hast dir gar nichts
gedacht das war dann immer maria 81 hat
sadie grace und alles was mit schlafen
zu tun also vorhänge auch ich festhalten
machen wir jetzt im bett über
gegenrichtung war kommen so sagen wie
beispielsweise songs oder antrat
wenig später um nicht mehr dann selbst
gemaltes bild
unseren münchen geschrieben dass dieses
doofe dann habe ich auf jeden fall die
sache die ehrenwache zu gehen die hessen
kassel ganz kurz denn die waren so
scheiße teuer aber so brauch so scheiße
geil ich dachte am anfang einmal die
erstmal da wo ich hier aber das ist
einfach nur ein bett ein kurzes ich
wusste nicht dass das fliesen sind bis
es irgendwann gesagt
sprachen lernen das ist dass das war ein
spiel
mussten die endgeräte beleuchtung die
haben das ist ja auch richtig steckdosen
darf man nicht sehen
steckdosen immer hässlich deswegen
oder auch im überall sieht man sich fast
einig so steckdosen bei mir nach
das klo wenn ich für diese produktion
immer ganz gut also telefone von hier
strich hier und als sicherheit klo und
ja hast du dusche deswegen der toilette
hier badewanne die ich exakt immer
zweimal benutzt haben zwei jahren unter
der leitung
von ganze woche werden 230 das ist alles
gezeigt meine kamera kunst waren glaube
ich nicht so super 8 wir sehen uns
ausschütten sondern bier ist in diesem
durchgang und hier wenn man allerdings
schlägt kann man sagen
diese decken die haben nämlich den
tiefen von je 8 9 cm oder so und hat
eine komplett verschließen und kann man
bald komplett verschließen also wir
schon merkt es ist mir wichtig gewesen
dass alles in wie clean ist das alles
offen ist dass man hier licht harz viel
natürliches licht das wollen wir noch
wichtig weiß ich nicht aber mein amt ja
ich glaube wir sind auch durchfall alles
gesagt
total banale dinge wie torwart diese
austria auf jeden fall ich direkt beim
einzug gemacht sondern erst jetzt weil
wir wie gesagt einige situationen hat
und die zuschauer vor der tür sie schon
ihr vor der tür zu schonen treppenhaus
soll teilweise in box insidern briefe
geschrieben oder so das ist ja alles
schön und süß und so aber es geht ein
bisschen an die privatsphäre dann so ich
will mich damit überhaupt nicht
beschweren es ist halt mein job das
gehört dazu so ein bisschen aber ich
hatte chef ist es noch mehr wird wenn
ich allen zu zeigen und so ein grundriss
und aufregung labbadia ist aber eh nicht
mehr hier mit und lieferungen auch
nichts mehr ist ist es scheißegal
allerdings würde ich an der stadt die
jugend wird auch beenden ich bin ab
jetzt wieder in köln
und du bist jetzt außen